just barack obama half-game or not yes
he does
yes he's smooth man he got a nice jump
shot he knows how to play hmm he has
instincts for the game too which was
really I was really shocked when he
invited cookie and I to come and they
were throwing a barbecue at the White
House and we the day before the barbecue
they were going to play a game of
pick-up basketball and it was just
amazing to be out there on that court
with him and some of the other
congressmen and Senators and it was just
amazing going up and down and just and
he hit the game-winning shot come on and
he yes yes he did he he pump-faked about
20 feet out oh and shot it and left his
hand up in the air to say like you know
I just hit the game-winning shot right
yeah so but it was a great moment in
time for me and for all the guys who
were invited and he's just you know he's
a game changer
I think he really changed the world and
just for the better and so he got game
bro he got me I gotta tell you there's a
lot of things that are cool about Barack
Obama but the fact that he built a
basketball court at the White House for
me is the absolute coolest I mean he put
it in I can tell you what Dwight
Eisenhower did not put in a basketball
court that's for sure
I love that there's a basketball court
at the White House now it's the greatest
thing ever
well also that he knows how to play
right yeah he's like you know normally
you know you get the president he's not
gonna know how to play no basketball so
you know I mean he can really really
play and and he loved the golf and and
he loves to talk trash - he was out
there talking trash I will
to rob that she was talking big-time
trash at the same time I love that
here's the president talking trash to
you what do you say back Rob what do you
say back when you look over there and
the Secret Service is standing right
there I don't think you really respond